i know you like nothing more
than a number with a name so we're going
to do witness numbers
they can provide witness
for your good character or more
specifically
they provide a witness for if a number
is prime or not and there's nothing we
enjoy more in mathematics than working
out if a number is prime or not i'm
curious to know whether 747 is prime oh
that's lovely if you add the digits
together as 18 so spoiler it's not prime
it's gonna be a multiple of nine but
let's say we don't know that
is 747
prime well here's what we're going to do
we're going to call up a witness to
testify on behalf of 747
to say whether or not it's prime and you
can you can choose your witness it's any
number smaller than 747 so from now on
this is like our n this is the number
we're interested in what witness would
you like to call
to represent your number i'd like to
call the number 23 23 nice so a is going
to be our uh witness 23. i'm using the
standard letters in case people want to
research this afterwards you've called
witness 23. so first of all we've got to
prepare your end for trial we want to
rearrange it to be powers of two so sum
i don't know what number we're going to
have up here there's gonna be some
number m which will be how many twos
there are and then that's multiplied by
some other number and then because
okay we're assuming this is odd this
actually this works for odd n greater
than two and if it's not an odd n
greater than two it's pretty obvious if
it's prime or not so we don't worry
about that so this is definitely going
to be odd and that's going to give us
something even because we're multiplying
by a whole bunch of twos plus one so
this is the form we want to put our
number in just to get it ready it's like
putting on a suit and a tie when you go
to court so actually let's get a
calculator i'm trying to minimize the
mistakes this time minimize the mistakes
not eradicate it just you know i'm
trying to cut back okay so we got uh 740
we're gonna take one off so it's gonna
be six and i'm just gonna see if i can
divide it by two
i can two goes into it once
is that it
that's it okay right cool that'll be
easy so that's going to be 2 to the
power of 1 times 373.
so now our m is 1 and d the leftover
chunk is 373. so what you're doing is
you're going let's pretend it's a power
of two but then
we've got to multiply it by something
and add one to x because it's not
actually a power two but this is this if
it was that's you know what it would be
okay so now we're going to ask right a
is
a
to the power of whatever this d is does
that equal one more then that's our
question very simple question and it's
either going to say yes or no and so
let's find out shall we so we've got to
do
we're going to do 23
to the power of 300 and terrible choice
brady sorry i hate to be
retrospectively critical of your choice
oh my goodness now computationally it's
not that bad because of this mod so if i
said what's 23 to the power of 373 it
would be a nightmare because that's
going to be like an outrageously big
number
but because we can mod it by n each time
we're never going to have a number any
point that's bigger than 747 so each
time we multiply 23 by 23 by 23 by 23 we
just keep modding by uh 747 uh i'm i'm
going to cheat and uh ask what from
alpha so
yeah
seven four seven okay well from after
that and
we did we did 23 to the power of 373
mod 747 and it was 131. now this is not
one it's got some ones in it but that's
not what we're after in this case the
first witness has come up and said nah
not prime and if a single witness says
not prime
that's it the number is kicked out of
the court or whatever this the prime
test place they are turfed out they are
not a prime number the moment of witness
says no so this is foolproof matt if we
get
one
we can take it to the bank no
so
this is how it works if a witness says
not prime you can totally believe them
that no witness is ever going to lie and
say it's not prime it actually is
however
some witnesses will lie
and say it's prime when it's not so
you'll never get a false negative
you will occasionally get a false
positive so not all witnesses
are reliable when they say yes and
they're literally called liars they're
called strong liars because they give an
absolutely definitely 100 that number's
prime
you have to believe me and they're lying
a non-one we can trust you fail yep yep
but a one isn't an absolute guarantee no
not an absolute guarantee i'll tell you
what let me do another one and i'll show
you i'll show you a liar in action so
same style as before but this time our
number again is not a prime so we're
going to do n equals 91.
not a prime number we're going to call a
witness we're going to call the number
10. maybe all right 10 get in here we
want to hear all about 91. well first of
all we've got to get them all dressed up
for court and so that's going to be our
plus one at the end it's going to leave
us with 90. so we're going to have 2 to
the 1 times 45. so our d value is 45.
okay so we get a and we're like radio a
10 to the power of 45 which is going to
be very big number what does that equal
if we're going mod 91 so
having a good old-fashioned think giving
us 90. now first of all you're thinking
hang on failed the test
however interestingly 90
is negative 1. mod 91 because it's one
below and so actually we will accept
positive or negative one all right so
that that should be a pass actually then
yeah so it's passed so tens like nah
checks out love it
put it in the mix and you're like okay
do we trust 10 let's say we picked a
number below 91 at random and the number
says yep it's prime and you're like well
i don't know how much i trust it should
we check another one well i happen to
know
below 91 there are 19 numbers so there's
90 possible witnesses we could call of
those 18 of them are liars so
there's an 18 out of 90 chance that when
we picked a number at random i happen to
know tim was a liar
it's going to be a liar and so now
you're like well hang on how does this
help and so sadly at the moment what we
have is a probabilistic
primality
test so it'll it it's an absolute
composite number test if it says it's
composite it is if it says it's prime
you're like
i don't know now if every number you're
like forget it bring all 90 possible
witnesses in here if all 90 of them are
like nah it's definitely prime then it's
definitely prime so you can't have
all liars can't have all liars so 18 is
just below
a quarter of 19. this is one of the
worst cases but for any number
maximum a quarter of the possible
witnesses will be liars and so now
you can just keep calling up witnesses
at random and it has to be at random
that are smaller than the number you're
testing and each time you test it worst
case there's a one in four chance and so
what you can say is if you do k tests
and you're picking properly at random if
they all say it's prime for k times then
there's a one over four to the k chance
it's not actually prime worst case this
is now now we're talking about
probabilities of probabilities because
it's it's below this that's like your
worst case so it's that or better so
what you do is you're like well you know
what if i want to be
99.9
sure
you just do enough tests to get you past
that limit and so because
computationally
doing multiplications and mods computers
are very happy with that oh and the one
extra
um thing you can do is a witness
can request
that as well as just having this d at
the front
it can have any extra multiples of two
out the front
but not as many as the original
breakdown so here we had a two here we
had one two
if this had been something like two
cubed or two to the four
then you could put in a bunch of twos
here and if any of them give you a one
or a negative one then that's a yes
so you've got to check a few things all
of them are very fast for computers to
do and so when you go to one of these
websites is this number prime and it's
like pretty sure it's prime what it's
doing is it's doing a test like this
often this exact test and it's using
that to just be able to say with some
level of confidence yeah we're pretty
sure that's prime in the case of 91 yep
10 is a liar that's a lie along with 17
other numbers you said correct
is there a number that is notorious for
being a liar more often than other
numbers you know you are so close the
opposite there are star witnesses there
are some witnesses where
if you if you're going to pick anyone
the this is the a team or witnesses you
want to call upon in fact they're so
good that you don't even have to call
any non-style witnesses
so i said you could just check all the
numbers in fact for any number below
a trillion
there's a squad of four witnesses and if
you ask all four of them and they all
sign off on it you're guaranteed let's
meet them here we go
yes
these absolutely these are there these
are okay let's get some more paper i
should also say that this is called the
miller rabbin test and you can do the
probabilistic version or you call out
your star witnesses and then you know so
if your only witnesses are two and three
if they cosign and say nah great number
definitely a prime that will work for
any number up to one million three
hundred and seventy three thousand six
hundred and fifty
three any number below that if you are
just asked two and three you're good now
that that is a speedy primality test
interestingly you'll have no idea what
the prime factors are of this number and
i'm i'm
fascinated by prime tests where you
don't divide and you don't even know
what the factors are you just know they
exist i find that so interesting but at
that point for that number there
one of those two will lie yeah one of
them cracks i don't know what this
number did
to one of these but there's been some
witness tampering going on and they've
now got they're now they're now upset so
what you do is you bring in another
witness you're like okay from now on
we're doing two we're doing three and
we're doing five
very primy get to that in a moment now
five not only does five sort out this
one five gets you all the way up to 25
million specifically 25 million 320
so it'll break on this number so it
works all the way up to a thousand flat
and so by bringing in one extra start we
only got three star witnesses you're
doing all right that said we could have
in here like let's say we're so
disappointed
that that these witnesses let us down
these folks were unreliable for this
number we're like get out of here you
know what we're going to replace you
with a equals 31 or 73 i mean bigger
chunkier numbers
but if you just use these two as
witnesses that works all the way up to 9
million
190 better star witnesses if you only
got space for two
then i would recommend bringing in 31
and 73 they make a bit more mess they're
not as well behaved as two and three but
they will get you you know over eight
times as far they're hostile witnesses
but they're honest exactly yeah yeah
they get they get it done
people may not approve of their methods
get the job done all right and then
before i said the the squad of four so
this is if you bring in and like this is
like for a really important case you're
like you know what we cannot mess around
and these these folks were only
discovered in 1993. these are expert
witnesses these are expert they're like
this is the 18. two
classic two forget three though you want
to bring in 13 you want to bring in 23
and then uh the team captain one million
six hundred and sixty two thousand eight
hundred and three
they're a real maverick
so
not good to work with
they've been many times i've had to hand
in their badge all that
but they will crack
the hardest of holdouts so uh these guys
will get you oh these are the guys who
get you over a quadrillion so this is
like a good cop bad oh yeah this is good
yeah good cup
bad cop
gets results
these get you all the way up to oh my
goodness uh one quadrillion
122 trillion four
million six hundred and sixty nine
thousand six hundred and thirty
three so good reach that'll mess around
all right matt you've shown me the star
witnesses but you still haven't told me
who are the liars you know i don't know
i i it had not occurred to me to look up
who were the least reliable and so i
mean you could do it you just have to if
someone wants to write some code
and put the answer in the comments below
i think it'd be very interesting you
just have to go through every single
number find out how many strong liars
it's got when you put it through the
miller rabbin test score each number for
how often it shows up as a liar and then
we'll know who the most dishonest
numbers are these are the honest numbers
oh by the way if you wanted if this
proves to be too much you can actually
replace them with two uh friendlier
numbers you can switch to two
three five
seven
eleven
i mean you just get back to the primes
so actually runs the primes are really
good they get you all the way up to 2
trillion 152
billion 302 million 898
thousand
oh
747.
let's put a little bow on this video
isn't it um yeah so it depends if you
would rather have fewer but unruly
witnesses or you prepared you've got
like a fifth chair and you bring you you
can bring in seven and 11 to to do the
lifting so oh what you need to do is you
need to find out what the 12 best out
and call them the 12 12 12 good numbers
you can't handle the truth uh 12 angry
numbers
i bet there is a 12 hang on so if you
want to put them in red for being angry
so here's your
they don't take any malarkey from anyone
you're bringing in two you're bringing
in three
five oh this is the prime 7 11 13 17 19
and 37. just off the top of my head that
will get you up to 308
sextillion i assume 665
quintillion
857 quadrillion i'm just gonna write the
numbers out or
approximately 10 to the 23. that's the
kind of order of magnitude you're
looking at you'd have to use all twelves
you've got to use they they all has to
be you can't have a hung jury it's
you've got to have completely unanimous
they've all got to be like yep
and in unison as a team if they all say
yes they're right
whether it's prime numbers composite
numbers or almost anything else why not
sharpen your skills with the amazing
array of courses on brilliant today's
episode sponsor
for a deeper understanding of how things
work you just can't beat interactivity
and that is brilliance stock and trade
as you can see
i can't really decide if this is
recreation or education i guess it's
both i recommend you check out brilliant
and if you're already signed up why not
consider giving brilliant as a gift to
someone else that inquisitive nephew
maybe or how about that auntie who's
always been a lifelong learner there's
plenty of free stuff on the site but
brilliant are offering a 20 discount on
their all-inclusive premium package by
using the url brilliant.org
number file it's there on the screen and
in the description give them a look
brilliant they're great people and
they're making amazing stuff